un invité politique cantonale relais
bonsoir bonsoir vous diriger le
mouvement des jeunes démocrates c'est le
parti de françois bayrou il ressent quoi
ce soir françois bayrou ils sont ils
sont fâchés ou pas avec avec le nouveau
président de la république on n'arrive
pas bien à savoir envoyer ce matin
françois bayrou se ronger les ongles ou
émis à une belle accolade après mais bon
tout cela n'est-il pas que de l'image
je pense qu'il est ravi je pense que
nous sommes tous heureux aujourd'hui de
cette passation de pouvoirs et de voir
qu emmanuel macron a réussi son pari qui
continuent à porter les valeurs qui
l'ont amenée jusqu'à la victoire et
qu'il a conscience des enjeux qui seront
face à lui pendant tout ce quinquennat à
vous parler comme un politique c'est
formidable vous avez quoi quel âge on
peut savoir
j'ai le temps j'ai 29 ans 29 ans jeune
homme dites-moi plus sérieusement est-ce
que est-ce que ça se calme chauffer ça
tangue et là c'est honnête de douala les
jours puisque quand vous découvrez la
liste extrêmement restreinte des
candidats modem finalement vous vous
étiez passé de 120 à 39
franchement il a failli avoir une porte
qui se claque il ya eu un malentendu et
en moins de 24 heures il a été résolu
malentendu pour ne pas dire malaise non
je pense que c'est c'est le propre d'une
victoire suite à une victoire on a une
tendance démons on va dire qui est celui
de se recroqueviller sur soi-même entre
victorieux je pense qu emmanuel macron a
bien conscience qu'il n'a pas gagné seul
et qu'il ne gouvernera pas seul il veut
une majorité élargie et donc je pense
qu'il est il a remis les les
les points sur les i pour que la
majorité qui sera la sienne à
l'assemblée son hôtellerie socialiste en
clair quoi un peu trop socialiste de
listes la première liste est sorti il ya
je pense eu un petit reflex socialiste
on va dire un dernier remous qui a
essayé de conserver un petit peu de son
espace et je suis très content que cet
épisode soit derrière nous et qu'on ait
pu résoudre le problème est quand même
françois bayrou a renoncé à se présenter
à la présidence pour soutenir emmanuel
macron c'est pas rien lalande est quand
même quelque chose
la question n'est pas celle du passé
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et président
de la république c'est bien une réponse
de politique je suis pas politicien ton
plein jeu
l'apport partiel voilà non c'est
simplement qu' il ne doit rien je pense
que sa victoire est la sienne
aujourd'hui il est président de la
république
c'est une très bonne chose il a besoin
d'une majorité à l'assemblée pour
gouverner pour appliquer son programme
nous souhaitons le soutenir dans cette
démarche et je crois qu'il a conscience
du fait qu'il ne faut pas qu'il s'isole
avec un petit groupe on n'est pas en
marche on est la république en marche
qui regroupe le mouvement démocrate et
le parti en marche
c'est une alliance et nous allons
essayer de la rendre fonctionnel mais
finalement que que recherche ou que
recherchait françois bayrou est ce que
c'était de faire renaître le modem je
pense qu'un modem n'est pas mort et donc
il n'avait pas besoin de renaître
mais oui évidemment le faire exister si
vous préférez c'est françois hollande a
essayé de faire une politique modérée
après avoir fait une campagne très à
gauche et avec une assemblée très à
gauche il n'a pas réussi et c'est
d'ailleurs le terme qu'utilisent
emmanuel macron quand il parle du
quinquennat de hollande
il dit que hollande a été empêchée et
donc je pense que cette erreur politique
là il a bien en tête qu'ils ne
souhaitent pas la répéter qu'il sait que
pour gouverner au centre on a besoin du
centre je n'ai pas l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui le président élu emmanuel
macron réalise le vieux rêve ou font
inachevé de force bayrou il consistait à
dépasser les partis mettent quelque
chose au-delà de faire se parler des
deux familles qui étaient jadis sont
agoniste c'est pas un vieux rêve c'est
un rêve qui me semble tout à fait
d'actualité ailleurs excellent
absolument qui a été réalisé nous avons
vu ces images sur le documentaire qui a
paru récemment du soutien clair et et
franc de françois bayrou à emmanuel
macron je pense que nous sommes tous
heureux de voir ce clivage dépassé vous
pensez que les républicains je sais pas
si c'est vous êtes la bonne personne à
qui poser cette question vont peut-être
commencé à franchir le pas après une
telle journée est ce que c'est jouable
selon vous parce qu'il faut des
républicains pour que ça marche il faut
pas qu'on s'arrête sur un rassemblement
partiel
je pense qu'il est important que notre
majorité soit la plus large possible on
en a besoin on a besoin que le président
matheron puisse agir et si une part des
républicains au moins arriver à oublier
les clivages qui ont été qui les ont
portés sur les derniers mois et a
participé à une majorité je pense que ça
serait grand pour la france on reproche
souvent aux responsables politiques
d'être complètement coupée de la réalité
du monde professionnel en particulier
là on a un président qui veut inclure
dans son gouvernement et notamment à
l'assemblée nationale s'ils sont élus
des représentants de la société civile
c'est ça la république que vous
souhaitez oui absolument
il faut pas qu'on soit sur des
politiciens de métier des gens qui
fassent uniquement ça de leur vie senna
autres cas moi c'est pas mon cas j'ai
une entreprise
je suis je donc je travaille j'ai je
gagne pas ma vie avec la politique j'ai
été conseiller municipal j'ai déménagé
j'ai démissionné aujourd'hui je ne suis
que engagé dans un parti mais c'est pas
comme ça que je vis un train et que tout
le monde la société civile finalement la
citoyenneté l'appel à la citoyenneté
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous souhaitez
vous si on arrive à convaincre les
citoyens du fait que chacun peut
participer que la république est à eux
et pas seulement à une caste de
politiciens qui se reproduisent
je pense que ça sera une très bonne
nouvelle pour la république nous avons
besoin que les français aient confiance
dans le fait qu'ils sont représentés par
des gens qui ont conscience de nos
problèmes à tous et qui sont
représentatifs quand je vois des gens
comme cédric villani qui sont candidats
moi je trouve ça formidable
nous avons peu de scientifiques
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale nous
avons besoin d'une bonne connaissance
des enjeux scientifiques on voit ce que
ça donne
aux etats unis quand il n'ya plus de
scientifiques au gouvernement et quant à
sion c'est oublier la culture la science
l'éducation plus on aura une assemblée
représentative de la france
mieux on se portera elle vous êtes
conseiller municipal à viroflay dans les
dans les yvelines je l'étais je viens de
demis ou venez juste de dire que j'ai
déménagé
vous êtes donc très attachés à cette
démocratie participative est ce que
c'est ça la politique de demain je pense
on ne peut plus gouverner
mais seuls emmanuel macron n'a pas
réussi sa conquête seul il a été rejoint
par énormément de gens certains de la
politique certains dans société civile
et il a réussi ce pari incroyable qui
est d'avoir convaincu et la france
entière ou en tout cas au moins au
second tour sur seulement un an et ça
c'était participatif
vous avez donc moins de 30 ans à vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure 29 ans très
précisément comment vous avez vécu cette
passation de pouvoir ce matin entre
françois hollande et emmanuel macron 39
ans dix ans de plus que vous seulement
quelque part est ce que est ce que son
son aventure vous tente et ce que son
aventure vous vous inspire un profond
respect une une admiration un profond
respect pas uniquement pour le
personnage mais pour la france qui a
réussi à élire un candidat qui est à la
fois jeune récent politique qui n'est
pas forgée dans le moule de des hommes
politiques on avait jusqu'ici
et surtout quel message on envoie à la
france entière et au monde entier en
leur disant que non la france et par un
vieux pays où seuls des politiciens
anciens gouverne mais on est capable de
se renouveler
vous auriez pas de vous engager auprès
d'emmanuel macron si vous n'aviez pas
été avec le le modem de françois bayrou
je me suis engagé via le mouvement mais
avant je pense que si françois bayrou
n'avait pas existé j'aurais certainement
été dans l'équipe des modèles maquereau
en tout cas vous voyez comme premier
ministre m et saut aux citoyens du modem
nouvelle équipe demain nommé alors je
vais attendre
je pense que c'est éminemment une
décision qui est celle du président sans
doute edouard philippe c'est un bon
profil pour pour le premier ministre
je sais que son nom a été partagée mais
vraiment je je n'aime pas
m'a donné à la prudence version so lu
ment et vous votre action politique au
quotidien ressemble à quoi
aujourd'hui on prépare les élections
législatives
on a de très nombreux très nombreux
candidats qui ne sont pas d'anciens
députés on a une formidable opportunité
avec sept élections législatives parce
que il y à une concordance des
événements à la fois le non cumul des
mandats qui arrive en vigueur donc de
nombreux députés maires qui doivent
choisir entre le mandat de maire et
celui de député
beaucoup choisissent celui de mer donc
on a un large espace pour le
renouvellement et puis une nouvelle un
nouveau courant qui s'est créé avec d'un
côté en marge le côté le mouvement
démocrate est donc une opportunité de
renouvellement avec la parité avec une
vraie représentation de la société
civile et ça c'est une très bonne chose
la moralisation de la vie politique à
laquelle très attaché emmanuel macron ça
aussi c'est une priorité pour vous
absolument j'espère que ce sera et il
l'a déjà répété que ce sera la première
action du nouveau gouvernement
nous avons souffert sur les dernières
années de plusieurs scandales qui
auraient pu être évités par des règles
claires et strictes
on a ce genre de règles qui existent
dans les pays voisins
nous avons besoin d'être plus franc sur
le fait que l'assemblée nationale la
politique en france doit être exemplaire
elle ne peut pas se permettre de laisser
le doute planer sur son intégrité
vous êtes un européen convaincu
absolument la jeunesse doit être
européenne nous aviez peur quelque part
que tous les sentiments populiste qui se
développe en europe actuellement et
puissent aussi gagné la france c'était
un risque très fort parce que sur les
quatre candidats qui étaient en position
d'arriver au second tour marine le pen
jean-luc mélenchon françois fillon
emmanuel macron le seul véritable
européen était emmanuel macron est
emmanuel macron et ça va redonner un
souffle incroyable à l'europe après
l'épisode du bric site que d'avoir un
président jeune clairement européen et
qui a envie de réformes et l'europe est
de faire de l'europe l'europe des
citoyens et pas seulement l'europe des
chefs d'état qui était celle qui était
souhaitée par françois fillon d'un mot
antonin grelet président du mouvement d
jeunes démocrates vous n'avez pas encore
30 ans vous regardez ce président qui en
a 39
c'est une france qui vous ressemble
aujourd'hui quelque il veut incarner
oui il sait qu'il est en terrain conquis
il sait que les parisiens sont presque
déjà convaincu par lui 90% des suffrages
exprimés et il a essayé aujourd'hui de
s'adresser à la france entière notamment
à ceux qui ne se sont pas reconnus dans
le vote pour macro